how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we have
something truly awesome
today we have a leaked audition tape for
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness which is seemingly somebody
auditioning for the role of america
chavez
we hear an actual script in what we can
assume to be dialogue from the movie
and it gives us a little bit of insight
on just what doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness is going to be
about
and there's a lot in here there's over a
minute of this footage so we're going to
break it all down for you but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all the latest
mcu news and if you love doctor strange
be sure to subscribe so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a doctor strange funko pop just
subscribe
like the video leave a comment down
below to enter so here's the leaked
audition video
hi my name is lily resto i'm 13 years
old and i'm 5'1
not bad can i have another one of these
um
what do you call them oh oh pepperoni no
more pizza you need to tell us what's
happening
yeah but i'm hungry i don't care a giant
giant demon just took out an entire
block of our city trying to eat you
it didn't try to eat me it tried to
abduct me
why bring me a pepperoni and you'll find
out
i'll get it she's just a child exactly
i'm just a child there you go my day
thank you frank
okay so how familiar are you guys with
the multiverse
somewhat familiar just last year we
attempted to open a rift in reality
la la rift in reality that must have
been an exciting adventure
okay anyways let's say this pizza is the
multiverse
here's my home reality and over
here is yours they're identical in some
aspects but completely different than
others
for instance you're both in better shape
where i'm from
sorry until a few weeks ago i didn't
know
any of this stuff i was just a
mild-mannered orphan
until one day a demon shows up and
attacks me
that was your visual aid pointing to two
pepperonis
yeah you guys are fast planners
okay so as you can see that was a lot
now it's almost a hundred percent
confirmed that this is the audition for
america chavez now one thing that you
need to know about america chavez is
that she has the ability to
travel through multiverses and that's
made very clear when she says
let's say this pizza is the multiverse
here's my home reality and over here
is yours they're identical in some
aspects but completely different than
others
so what appears to be happening here is
that she's explaining to somebody
possibly doctor strange or another
hero that she's not actually from the
current universe that she's in
now she could be in the main earth
universe but she could be in a different
one
however the dialogue that says so how
familiar are you guys with the
multiverse and the other person says
somewhat familiar just last year we
attempted to open a rift in reality
this could be referring to the events of
avengers in game we don't exactly know
when doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness is going to take place but
there's no reason to not assume that it
couldn't take place
immediately after the events of avengers
in-game because that is
when the multiverse technically gets
ripped open a lot of different timelines
were created in avengers end game even
though the avengers were trying to be
careful and even though they returned
all of the infinity stones and that's
why the multiverse
is going to be in madness and it does
seem like whatever
universe she is currently in is kind of
chaotic right now one of the first
lines is a giant demon just took out a
block of our city and tried to eat you
in which she replies it didn't try to
eat me it tried to abduct me
now demons of course are widely
associated with doctor strange and
considering the fact that doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness is
supposed to be somewhat of a horror type
film
demons fit the bill pretty well now
there are many guesses of who this demon
could be but right now nothing is
confirmed
it could be mephisto it could be
nightmare it could be dormammu
demon is kind of a vague term and as far
as the script goes it could just be a
placeholder so in case this video got
out which it did
nothing would be given away but one
thing that is for sure after this video
got leaked is that
people from other universes are going to
be coming to the main
mcu timeline which means that of course
doctor strange is probably
going to be going to other different
universes as well so the possibilities
of
what characters that we could possibly
see are essentially endless
and like the girl said in the video
there are different versions of
different characters in the other
universes
that means this opens up the potential
to see a different iron man
and a different captain america along
with a bunch of different other versions
of characters
so doctor strange and multiverse of
madness seems to be shaping up to be a
truly fantastic movie as if anybody
really had any doubt but let me know who
you think
this demon is do you think it's mephisto
nightmare do you think dormammu is
returning let me know all your thoughts
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
can stay up to date on
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe for live updates you
can follow me on twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you